on this Thursday night Donald Trump face
to face with a federal judge again just
as a very sad day for America the former
U.S president's plea on criminal charges
he conspired to steal the 2020 election
his possible trial date exhausted
risking their lives and grieving you're
pushing the limits of what humans can do
what these crews are fighting Beyond
BC's wildfires vehicle Shoppers forced
to hit the brakes what's driving up
prices and depleting inventory
global national with Donna Friesen
former U.S president Donald Trump in
Washington D.C arrested and arraigned
for a third time an unprecedented moment
in American history cameras not allowed
inside the courthouse today as Trump
pleaded not guilty to charges he
conspired to defraud the U.S and cling
to power good evening and thanks for
joining us there have been so many
unimaginable first so many lines crossed
since Trump first ran for president that
it's hard to keep track of them but this
is the most significant and serious
legal case against him prosecutors
allege he knew he'd lost the 2020
election and yet was part of a scheme to
try to overturn the results Jackson
prosco is outside the courthouse Jackson
take us through what happened
well Donna this is becoming a bit of a
well rehearsed routine for the former
president he leaves his home he flies to
another city for a brief court
appearance and that's exactly what
happened today Trump appeared in
Washington D.C for a very procedural
court hearing entering that not guilty
plea he was seated about five meters
away from special counsel Jack Smith and
we understand the two did make brief eye
contact during that hearing the former
president was given a list of release
restrictions they include not discussing
the case with Witnesses if he violates
those conditions he could find his bail
revoked effectively here Donna really
though the former president as he left
the courtroom made it clear he is
defiant and he is chalking this up to
what he calls political persecution
this is a very sad day for America this
is a persecution of a political opponent
this was never supposed to happen in
America this is the persecution of the
person that's leading by very very
substantial numbers in the Republican
primary and leading Biden by a lot so if
you can't beat him you persecute him or
you prosecute him we can't let this
happen in America
Jackson lots of hyperbole there I think
Trump and Biden the polls are actually
neck and neck Trump is running to be
president again though is the trial
likely to happen before or after the
2024 election
well this is where things are going to
get interesting the next Hearing in this
court case is just in a couple of weeks
from now and that's where they're going
to lay out the trial schedule and
special counsel Jack Smith has made it
clear he wants a speedy trial perhaps
one starting within the next 90 days
Trump's defense team though wants the
exact opposite they want to kick the can
down the road as far as possible they
want this dealt with after the 2024
election believing that Trump can win
and that a trump-led justice department
can effectively disappear the charges
where this ends up is a big question
right now and the other thing we have to
keep in mind here Donna is that Trump's
schedule is pretty packed with court
hearings over the next year or so
between this indictment the other
federal charges in the documents case
the New York case and the looming
indictment in Georgia somewhere in the
middle of all that he's going to try and
run a presidential campaign all right
Jackson prosco in Washington thank you
now to the wildfires in Canada more than
1 000 active fires are burning about a
third of them in BC among those being
closely watched are the Downton Lake
Fire it's 110 kilometers Northwest of
Whistler fire officials say at least
five structures have been lost in the
Gun Lake Area more than 200 properties
were issued evacuation orders on Tuesday
and in South Central BC the Lower East
Adams Lake Fire is burning north east of
Kamloops while the Ross Moore Lake Fire
is burning south of that City our nitu
garchagod access to Crews doing
dangerous work there nitu Donna BC Crews
have a lot to think about under
increasingly hot dry and windy
conditions but what's at the Forefront
for many of those here on the front line
is the firefighters who've lost their
lives this season while doing the same
job they are
from the air you can see how this out of
control Wildfire about 10 kilometers
away from Kamloops BC has jumped
containment lines and moved fast due to
Changing Winds
you're pushing the limits of what humans
can do in this job a lot of the time
with their physically emotionally or
intellectually just the the
the amount you have to manage at any
given moment the situations you have to
be part of aus Al Mubarak is a task
force leader he says hearing a 25 year
old firefighter was killed battling
fires in BC over the weekend the fourth
to die in Canada this season has taken a
toll on everyone Fred being the fourth
it definitely hit us hard
crew safety is also top of mind for
Simone Bermudez who's cutting down
dangerous trees in their way there is
inherent risk always we understand that
and when something like this happens
like the the death unfortunately that
occurred this year everybody feels it
you know our red shirt the red shirt our
BC crews are spread out far and wide
former fire investigator Adam Buchanan
says trees like this one burnt only on
one side help determine which direction
the fire traveled the fire progressed
this way
took a good run on the first day it
burnt all the roots and if we get down
we can see this goes for a long long way
we can't just spray water on the top and
this could still be burning 10 12 15
feet down any one of these routes that
we're looking at all signs of how dry
the fuels are we have consistently seen
busy fire seasons and I think it's it's
just getting used to that and knowing
what we're we're getting into each year
with the climate it's been a long summer
and there's moments where
I'm tired and I just want it to be
winter again
from what I've seen this week there
isn't a BC firefighter here who isn't
exhausted the service has been stretched
thin since April and with August ahead
of us they're urging everyone to do
their part to prevent any human-caused
fires Donna all right need through
garcha near Kamloops BC thanks
[Music]
it's the danger that car plunged off a
collapsed bridge in northern China the
driver was rescued by other motorists
parts of the country are dealing with
flash flooding triggered by torrential
rains from typhoon daksuri emergency
crews are still scrambling to rescue
people who were stranded by the flood
water at least 22 people are known to
have died and that number is expected to
rise more than 1.2 million people have
been moved to safety Mike Armstrong on
China's unprecedented floods
is one of those statistics that's hard
to believe this city Southwest of
Beijing was hit by a Year's worth of
precipitation in one single rainfall
it's been volunteers going building to
building helping people escape
this woman had been stuck for four days
and says she barely slept she was too
afraid her home would collapse
according to the Chinese State
broadcaster tens of thousands of people
have been trapped in their homes there
have also been landslides and flash
floods that have cut off some areas
cruising multiple provinces are trying
to clear roads the typhoon has now been
downgraded to a tropical storm it's
moved Northeast and rains have tapered
off
what has been left is a region about
three times the size of New Brunswick
struggling with what comes next
waterways and reservoirs are over
capacity and authorities are trying to
find ways to discharge some of that
water safely
this man says his family lost their
entire a crop and there was nothing they
could do
another logistical problem has been with
rescue crews teams were being brought in
from other areas to help that has now
stopped according to reports there was
overcrowding on access routes and
coordination was turning into a safety
issue
rescue crews that are working have been
busy around the clock
residents are waiting for us to save
them this man says we have to grasp
every minute to save as many as possible
these are being called the worst floods
since 1996. in that year 2800 people
were killed new flood control systems
were brought in after that flooding they
are being tested this week as our rescue
crews Mike Armstrong Global News
demands to search a Winnipeg area
landfill site for the bodies of two
First Nations women are ramping up today
there was a show of solidarity at
Winnipeg's busy Portage and main
intersection
demonstrators created a giant red dress
at the intersection a symbol for missing
and murdered indigenous women Winnipeg
Police have said a search is not
feasible the Manitoba government says it
will not support a search of the
privately owned Prairie green landfill
because it could expose Searchers to
toxic chemicals protesters recently
blocked the entrance to another Winnipeg
landfill for nearly two weeks before
police removed that blockade
it's not certain whether we're headed
for a recession in Canada economists
take different views on that what is
certain is that summer travel is in full
swing and people are spending but there
is some unease about what's being called
a rich session and as Anne gaviola
explains the impact depends on your
income bracket
you probably can't tell because travel
demand is back with a vengeance and
luxury goods sales are robust but Canada
may be heading towards a different kind
of economic downturn a so-called Rich
session is an economic downturn that
primarily affects the wealthy it is the
opposite of a typical recession which
hits lower income people the most the
first signs may be Tech layoffs which
have already claimed many high-paying
jobs some economists predict pay cuts
for the highest earners and a pay bump
for the lowest lower wage workers blue
collar workers
gaining higher wages getting more power
thanks to the labor shortages
while we're seeing higher paid workers
maybe not gaining as much an uptick in
labor and rest may be one sign of this
financial recalibration this labor
studies professor says it's viewed by
Frontline workers as a long overdue
redistribution of wealth workers have
seen their real wages their purchasing
power are voting
a great deal under this inflationary
period And yet
large corporations have have made record
gains what has happened throughout the
20th century and the beginning of the
21st century especially through the
Great Recession was that we saw the
middle class sort of Disappearing many
analysts say we're already in a
so-called rolling recession where the
economy is dragged down by floundering
sectors like Tech but boosted by a
strong housing market energy industry
and the return of travel as for the
wealthy these higher income households
were very well up to begin with so they
had more savings they could tap into
that to where there's a storm well they
may finally feel the pinch of a
recession but they're well equipped to
get through it
and gaviola Global News Toronto
major roadblocks for car buyers coming
up what's fueling high prices and low
Supply
any hopes of Alberta hosting the 2030
Commonwealth Games have been dashed the
provincial government has pulled its
support for a bid it was going to be a
joint bid a partnership with the cities
of Edmonton and Calgary two First
Nations the federal government and the
province The Province cites Financial
feasibility concerns as the reason for
withdrawing support Edmonton last hosted
the Commonwealth Games in 1978.
buying a car has become more of a
challenge as Canada's automotive
industry steers out of a pandemic
pothole historically low inventories of
both new and used vehicles have pushed
prices higher than ever and buyers have
to wait months or years for their wheels
if they can even find a vehicle Korea
isri explains
Stephan Takis put a deposit down for a
Toyota Sienna a year and a half ago it's
been a little frustrating his family
needs a bigger vehicle he has three
children including a son with cerebral
palsy he's small enough now I can still
pick him up but eventually we'll need uh
probably one of those siennas with the
adapted
accessibility Takis has no idea if or
when it will arrive Jenny Alton has
spent eight months looking for something
basic but can't find anything in her
budget well I'm not looking to spend
forty five thousand dollars on a car
that I'm going to put 30 000k on and go
back and forth to work with I need
something to haul my lunch bag according
to auto trader the average price of a
new vehicle in Canada is now sixty two
thousand dollars vehicle prices for new
vehicles that are about 60 percent
higher at the retail level relative to
pre-pandemics price can be an obstacle
and so can supply this may seem like a
lot of vehicles on the lot but in
reality most of them are already sold or
spoken for while some best sellers are
nowhere to be found this dealership is
completely out of stock of the Ford
Escape pre-pandemic this this lot would
have three to four rows of full F-150s
plus it's not only new cars selling out
the cost of the used Civic has probably
never been higher because the demand and
for both new and used now because you
can't get them economists say supply
chain issues complicated most recently
by the BC Port strike are contributing
in part to the shortage I don't believe
we'll go back to 2019 prices and the
reason why is that cars are more
expensive to make overall electric
vehicles are especially expensive
automakers have also priorit s making
more high-end Vehicles where the profit
margins are bigger Takis doesn't want
anything fancy sure we can buy you know
something that's definitely less
efficient but nowadays everything's so
expensive a big ticket item that's
become even bigger and harder to get in
these challenging Economic Times teria
is rate Global News
Ottawa
dispute disruptions still ahead how the
strike of Hollywood actors and writers
is affecting Productions in Canada
American pop star lizzo says allegations
made in a lawsuit by three of her former
dancers are sensationalized stories
the Grammy winner known for promoting
body positivity denies the allegations
they include sexual harassment false
imprisonment racism and dancers saying
they've been body shamed in a statement
the singer calls that too outrageous to
not be addressed she says it's never her
intention to make employees feel
uncomfortable or like they aren't valued
the plaintiffs also allege lizzo
pressured them to attend sex shows and
touch naked performance and say they
were once forced to attend an
excruciating 12-hour audition
well there is some signs of Hope in the
strike by writers in the U.S film and
television industry after months of
picketing they'll be back at the
negotiating table with major Studios on
Friday actors are on strike too though
and as this job action impacts Canada's
entertainment industry it's prompting
this country's film and TV workers to
think about their own deals Mike trolley
reports
if it's a Canadian movie or TV show and
action there's still yelling action any
show with an American actor or writer
has had to hit pause putting Hollywood
North in a deep freeze Vancouver
Vancouver was was hit very hard uh they
have that's the largest
um you know U.S location uh in Canada
what do we want the strength involves
U.S writers and actors so far Canada's
version could be just around the corner
our negotiations come up in um in in
2024 so we're watching this really
closely their fight is our fight their
issues are our issues and uh and we'll
be continuing that fight when it's our
turn to get back to the table the hope
is that the American unions get a deal
that's transferable but that's no sure
thing
[Music]
the complicated compensation issues
around streaming services are one thing
but those pale in comparison to the new
technology on the Block artificial
intelligence which has seemingly
Limitless potential to disrupt the
industry it's why the unions are going
back to school we're in conversation now
with some academics from Stanford and
MIT like we're looking to bring in some
some high-powered academics you know you
got to know you got to know the You Know
The Enemy before you get it you know you
go to the table actors for one if your
Studios could have them on set one day
and then use their likeness over and
over without paying them if we are
allowing uh AI to produce itself at such
a rapid pace it trickles down into so
many areas in life that just becomes
unethical and immoral all around
Hollywood has had to adapt before the
switch from film to videotape and now
digital wasn't easy but producing deals
that maintain and reward the human
element in the computer age could be the
hardest script to write yet microlay
Global News Toronto
[Music]
Yukon we'd love to see your Canada
please email it to us and thanks for
watching Chris gayles will be at the
anchor desk tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]
thank you